you're welcome to this video playing em
five-minute blitz game against kitsune
Garvey yeah there's so many players on
icc i really think i'm on a daily basis
I meet people I never played before ok
f6 hmm yeah it's quite uncommon here but
usually if white manages to get in
Bishop d3 and 92 in this kind of
positions it's very nice you often have
problems with clock captive development
and this looks rather rather fluent now
ok I'm trying to clarify this central
position end with a 3 before it's all so
I'm gather spawn is removed on b2 that
can easily get on that text so I can
actually develop membership and um make
sure the center is protected ok I'd like
to go nite a 45 this a six but should be
seven it looks like he's trying from
night a seven and we should be five so
this I'd like to I like to prevent if
possible so cal castle I can take twice
here
okay let's let's go here it was the idea
anyway and I don't think he can allow 97
the king and the center wouldn't be
secure really yeah but what else really
yeah this looks this looks terrible will
it be 67 v6 is the only move now
otherwise black is basically passage
okay if you don't manage how do you now
get out of this being tied to the beep
on all the time v6 was the only move
I don't really think that like an black
an them held this okay the question is
there should i play 95 here directly but
he's got h6 okay if I castle night f5 he
might play Bishop b5 this is in fact
interesting yeah we should be five this
would help him maybe I should play a
form you know a four to prevent Bishop
b5 so one night have five question is
should i take it yeah this is the simple
solution not sure if it is the best one
but it's am at least easy to play now so
look rook should be 6 i'm not sure
let's exchange 11 powerful CM the rooks
are very active and exchanging one
should be helpful check so yeah I didn't
play this too great it's um I shouldn't
have taken on f5 this was a bad decision
really here it's a it's nothing for
white that's even arguable that black is
better here because of the light squares
it can invade maybe with the bishop yeah
it's not um not dramatic I have taken an
f5 was really stupid black was really in
bad shape but I I played the terribly
yeah tries to invade with the Queen
I don't want to allow that but of course
this is the great bone structure you can
just take now and I think you should him
yeah the still fields rather drawers
unless night air force an instant
problem yaar 92
we should be too hmm
yeah but should be too but then I have
Bishop b3 after that a night before and
c6 this is my was my DM
mmm retreating yeah okay we can he can
do it do that it's not another problem
I just didn't didn't expect it
check
yes this is so dead wrong girl Alfred
yeah why is it here because I Ardra not
resigning yeah just bad bad bad play by
me yeah I'm not playing b6 it's just
it's just very bad and around here I
need to improve this position is it's a
strategical win almost it's just a
matter of precise plane yeah the
computer is on plus 24 white a bit much
but the gam it is very good what what's
the most precise way to play the promise
is always tied to the pawn and it's a
constant weakness what did I play I
guess I guess a4 a.m. I was worried
about Bishop b5 and this is maybe not a
problem at all amba should be 5 I can
play a form anyway now the computer now
gives this move with 2.5
yeah the ideas 95 yeah it is it is very
bad for black yeah so a form a force was
a mistake and then the next mistake is
probably taking I didn't really see a
good good alternative I didn't want to
retreat on the bishop all the way this
is answered by night f4 I don't want
that so this problem and I don't know it
doesn't feel right the company wants to
go here yeah this is in fact i'm already
quite tricky still good for white but
tricky yeah so then i took here and this
gives away the the the edge problem
these pieces are active now at he has
got this and this is a pretty good way
to secure the queenside i lost the
momentum here to check around here I'm
I'm worse because of the light squares I
mean I somehow kept it together but it
looked and it is tricky probably am with
the really good play black hood good gem
make some headway here think here the
worst was over with the the night check
yeah this is the easiest way to draw
because then i have the bishop on b6
that covers everything here just takes
and it's a perfect it's a perfect
fortress form for white yeah this year's
the instructive moment will be 60 strong
need to use the momentum attacking e6
alright thanks for watching